the value of Bitcoin which is the most
widely held as of right now
cryptocurrency ran up to almost twenty
thousand dollars a coin last week before
ultimately falling to about $14,000 in
change over the weekend then riding back
up and more and more people have gotten
involved in buying Bitcoin and in the
midst of this there was a major hack
late last week hackers got away with
seventy million dollars at the time of
the hack of Bitcoin and of course that
value really depends on what the value
is of each Bitcoin at any given time but
at the time it was about 70 million
dollars worth from the mining service
nice hash this was reportedly a
professional attack according to nice
hash although they haven't really said
much more than that and I don't know
that they will these incidents are
relatively rare but they're also not
nearly unheard of there were 31 million
dollars in tokens stolen from tether
whit which is an another coin
some time ago and etherium code bug read
to a led to about a hundred and fifty
million dollars of aetherium being
frozen coin - had an issue where 7
million dollars was stolen from
investors back in July and you know for
our audience and based on my relatively
limited knowledge of the technical side
of this it doesn't make a lot of sense
to even attempt to get into the micro of
how these security vulnerabilities exist
and and the security vulnerabilities are
technically different between these
different crypto currencies but the main
takeaway is that this is different than
having US dollars in an FDIC insured
American Bank there's no question about
that and the big picture when you hold
Bitcoin or other crypto currencies on
exchanges is that it's important to
understand that you don't really have
possession of it the exchange has
possession of it and it's sort of
assigns that cryptocurrency to your
account and there are ways for people
who are interested in this
of really taking position possession of
your Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
that are similarly structured by having
the private keys in wallets of your own
rather than in exchanges and again it's
not hugely relevant to most of our
audience but this is going to be a
growing issue and if you needed any
indication that cryptocurrency is really
splitting a lot of people because there
are those who are completely on the side
of this is the future of transnational
currency transactions and and the value
of these cryptocurrency is going to go
up indefinitely and and it's a great
thing to get into the other side is this
is totally worthless bubble fodder and
this is all going to crash
and it's a pyramid scheme and somebody's
going to get left holding the bag and
then there are sort of in-betweens which
say yeah you know there may be a bubble
but at the same time fiat currency that
many governments have is also not really
backed by anything of intrinsic value so
that this could become sort of
legitimate long term and and there is a
sign that it is at least becoming
somewhat more legitimate which is that a
number of financial exchanges are now
adding the price charts the price
tracking of sometimes a dozen sometimes
50 or even over a hundred currency
crypto currencies to their database in
addition to stocks and other mutual
funds so if if that is a barometer of
perceived legitimacy it appears that it
is growing but certainly every time you
hear seventy million in Bitcoin was
stolen it does undermine the perceived
stability and value of crypto currencies
every single time there's a headline
that like that for better or worse and
we'll be delving more into this in in
some future program interviews and
content so a big story from last week
and I don't know how much more we're
going to eventually learn about that 70
million dollar hack